[Music]  Niger's capital nia may has no regular  garbage collection so trash is often  burned at illegal dumping sites when  rubber tires burn they release toxic  substances environmental activist amina  issa a doe has found a brilliant way to  recycle tires thereby creating jobs for  local use her recipe take a tire  wrap it in foam rubber and decorate it  with beautiful fabrics that makes a seat  cushion in the traditional style of the  Sahel region they sell for twenty two  you rose appease the tourists and other  customers who buy them say these  cushions are more comfortable and even  last longer than traditional ones  it's no wonder they're made of rubber  do you like that if you are also doing  your bit tell us about it  visit our website or send us a tweet  hashtag doing your bit  we shared your stories